[Applaudissements]
carrière de l'espace merci m
il est arrivé ici personne ne le regarde
et maintenant c'est devenu le playboy de
la bande annonce vraiment à la vraiment
vous êtes vraiment devenu très très beau
gosse j'ai des chances avec c'est dire
le niveau des autres
[Rires]
c'est alors tous ceux qui aiment le
football le connaissent j'ai dit à mes
potes ce week-end que je faisais rentrée
ce garçon dans la bande et tulio la la
c'est le procureur le procureur ici on
vous appellera pas le procureur a bien
ouais vous appellera je ne vous
appellera pas d'ailleurs c'est gilles
verdez qui est avec nous berne elle sait
pas ce que vous en pensez
ça fait très mec qui se présente aux
municipales bonjour voter vers des
beautés verdès vous serez plus à l'aise
bien sûr je suis dans la 5e
circonscription bien entendu vers des
présidents mais assuré oui j'aime bien
et puis on voit que direct à la
présidentielle abba direct accord au
niveau coiffure on va faire quoi pendant
cette année j'ai à disposition
wells comme ça quelque chose on va
essayer on va rester comme ça pour le
moment on prend des risques on aime bien
isabelle morini bosc est là
mais j'avais morini-bosc il faut savoir
que tout le monde parlait et ça ça tape
arrêté sur twitter de son décolleté est
venue la défrayer la chronique et alors
ouï dire entre eux oui d'abord il ne
tombe pas c'était juste la position
ensuite je mettais pas rendu compte
et enfin la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'il
ya des gens qui ont enfin vu on avait un
petit peu raccourcir façon mois déjà
cuites nous donc c'est bien